you see these 65 year old women videos
going viral where they say I walked with
the feminist I bought into the Argan
being a feminist man was an enemy in my
life this lady says this is the most
touching lady she was not a good talk or
not she wasn't like she just regular
talking she's I'm 65 years old I've
never been married I have no kids I will
never be able to have kids I will never
be able to experience what it is to be
married to a man when I was in my 20s
the concept of feminism stole that away
from me
just because I looked at man as the
enemy and he's not
and a lot of people are going to go
through this and it's gonna suck because
this thing goes like this
[Music]